unbowed unbent unbroken the words of
house Martell a promise to our enemies
and a challenge to our lovers thousands
of years ago the warrior queen Nymeria
crossed into Dorne from Essos fleeing
the Dragonlords of a Lydia after she
landed she burned her ships all 10,000
of them so no cowards could slink home
what a woman
Dornish in spirit before she ever was in
flesh she was lucky to land in Dorne
where powerful women are not locked away
in SEPs and the beds of old men my
ancestor Moors Martell saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail a town may succeed wedding his
strength to hers his spear to her son
they subdued all his rivals together
after the tradition of her people house
Martell then ruled Dorne as princes not
Kings unless the eldest child was a
daughter for unlike the rest of Westeros
our loyalty isn't commanded by a [ __ ] we
follow a prince or a princess Martell
just the same and we always have some
people forget that Aegon Targaryen
crowned himself Lord of six kingdoms not
seven when his sister marched on Dorne
she found no mighty hosts drawn up
against her for her Dragon to burn in
her soldiers to slaughter the sands
swirled men died and her dragons saw
nothing the Sun shone men died and her
dragon bowed to our greater fire the
Targaryens retreated with their tails
tucked between their legs of course in
later years his descendants would try
again
they run the first succeeded at great
cost and reigned and dawn for a few
glorious months one night his steward
pulled down a sash by his bed to summon
his consorts instead the canopy split
open in a hundred red scorpions fell on
him
he was a Tyrell you would think he would
be used to getting stung within a
fortnight house Martell again ruled a
free door eventually after centuries of
courtship house Martell got into bed
with the Targaryens we took King they
run the second and his sister for our
own before they could take each other
and six kingdoms became seven even now I
do not blame my ancestors one look at
those long silver locks it is not every
day a man gets to ride a dragon but they
soon learned that you can't leap off a
dragon at will my sister Elia she
married Prince Rhaegar Targaryen and
became the princess she already was in
Dorne she walked among vipers and none
would bite her in King's Landing she
found herself surrounded by lions
when Robert Baratheon rebelled against
his rightful king his future
father-in-law Tywin Lannister ordered
his beast Gregor Clegane to rape and
murder my sister along with her helpless
children and Men called the Lannisters
heroes now Lannisters sit on the Iron
Throne
surrounded by the blasted sorts of
Aegon's broken foes I wonder if they
remember as I do
that none of those swords are ours I
wonder if they see as I do my sister's
red blood soaking into the stones of
their precious red cape maybe they need
reminding the lion may be a mighty beast
but pride always lifts his gaze to the
horizon never seeing in the grass the
Viper